Usually when researchers
are evaluating a learning algorithm,
they split their data into two chucks.
The training chunk, and a testing chunk.
Training usually is about 60% of
the data, and testing is about 40%.
Now if you train and
then test on that data,
that's one trial and in many
cases that's enough, you measured
your root means square error and
that's an assessment of your algorithm.
You might compare it
against another algorithm.
But one problem researchers
sometimes encounter
is they don't have enough data to
effectively analyze their algorithm.
One thing they can do is effectively
create more data by slicing it up and
running more trials.
Here's how that works.
So what we can do is we can slice our
data into say five different chunks,
and then we can train here on 80%
of the data, and test on 20%.
That's one trial.
Then we can switch things up and
train on this 80% of the data.
And test on that,
that's another trial, and so on.
I'm sure you see how this is going.
We can effectively get five different
trials out of this one set of data.